bueno primer en primer lugar es que sin
duda es una medida para compensar todo
lo que está afectando la crisis de todo
este tercer confinamiento duro
confinamiento acompañar a la compañía
del transporte a ellos en particular el
fans air france hay que recordar que la
principal línea aérea de francia y que
mueve gran parte y por tanto es un
importante actor no sólo para la
industria del transporte aéreo y el
turismo francés sino a nivel de la
economía general genera una serie de
aportes que en ese sentido está ayudas
directamente se interpretan como una
forma de compensar y ayudar el plan el
plan de sostenibilidad y transformación
de la empresa y ayudar a sortear la
crisis que por lo menos al menos en el
primer semestre del 2021 va a continuar
se va a estar hacia damente afectadas
ricardo porque esta estrategia es
diferente porque en el pasado vimos que
por ejemplo la aerolínea nacional de
hungría maalef recibió préstamos por
parte del estado la comisión europea
luego dijo que no eran legales que no
era válido tuvo que devolver ese dinero
y declararse en bancarrota vemos el
drama que tiene al italia con sus
inversionistas privados y con el estado
también en portugal está portugal la
tuvieron que vende
a manos privadas porque en este caso la
comisión si avala este 30 por ciento de
estos cuatro mil 700 millones de dólares
para france pero hay un análisis previo
en ese sentido hay un reconocimiento a
la labor que se ha hecho en forma de
avanzar en sostenibilidad no sólo como
compañía aérea y en presentar un plan
que estuve un negocio sustentable
precisamente la llegada del 2020 mittal
al gobierno de fans apunta a crear una
empresa sustentable en el tiempo y la
compañía de hecho en numerosas
transformaciones que va a continuar y ha
establecido una serie de compromisos en
esa línea y por tanto avalan todo le dan
garantías al estado francés y a la
comisión europea la unión europea en
entregar la ayuda cosa que no ha
ocurrido con la ordinaria como menciona
a la italia que es en un caso muy
complicado donde todavía nos vemos que
ya aparte arrastra bastante una serie de
ayudas que están todavía en
investigación hay que aclarar ese punto
y bueno están portugal y el caso de
manera que al final venían con un punto
de fuertes pasivos que termina
cerrando como recibe entonces la
competencia porque air france no es la
única aerolínea en el mercado francés
para recibir todos estos dineros la
ayuda del estado esto cae mal sin duda
alguna la competencia que hacer entonces
para igualdad
allí la balanza la gestión de los slots
que sólo derechos de aterrizaje y
despegue aterrizaje es la mejor fue una
forma de cómo ayudar a la competencia
los sin duda que cada vez por ser de
horas con otras líneas que operan en él
y se van a ver beneficiadas porque van a
poder incrementar capacidad con la
salida de fans que tiene domina gran
parte de este aeropuerto ahora para el
francés compromete también la favorece
porque va a poder concentrar sus
operaciones en un solo aeropuerto como
estar de bolt y mientras dejando el
resto de la competencia en el en orly lo
local en más baja desde bajo hacer mucho
la industria aérea de la francesa el
cargo del piano desde la ciudad de
santiago en chile muchas gracias por
analizar este tema para nuestra
audiencia aquí en france 24